we're ready for you your majesty three
two one
this is Jubilee take this is a day as
grueling as a Queen's coronation
twenty-five years ago people were on
days like today ask yourself and the
time I've been on the throne what am I
actually achieved country is bankrupt
our national security is in tatters if
that man wins the ones is out there is
no longer peacetime
this country was still great when I came
to the throat all that's happened on my
watch is the place is falling apart
you cannot flinch any fallen apart if we
say it is there's the thing about the
monarchy we paper over the cracks
[Music]
elder sister younger sister number one
and number two who was number one you
she knows it too yes I think she does
if I may offer two pieces of advice
never turn your back on true love in the
second watch out for your family they
mean well no they don't
we all have a role to play and I listen
to his family and I see the who and what
I am No
frustrations and resentments can build
up from a life as a support act
we have all made sacrifices and
suppressed who we are
it is not a choice it is a duty
you